Unicron is coming
how big can this guy be uh he eats planets so
like way bigger than a planet
let them come
For centuries our kind has
stayed hidden on Earth Prime
the darkness has found us again this
is about the fate of all living things
back up Oh I thought we were
boys
you brought a human here I'm nobody I ain't even
seen nothing I'm not even seeing anything rightnow
this is not our war Optimus we must trust
each other to protect the home we all share
in the end maybe there's another way to
save our home everything you cared for
will be consumed
you've never faced anything like this
Welcome back everyone it's Charlie this will
be my Transformers rise of the Beast trailer
video they finally revealed that Unicron
is actually the main villain of the movie
so I'll explain what's going on they've been
teasing Unicron in the Transformers movies for
a long time now if you're brand new to
the channel be sure to subscribe to get
all the videos I'll do a giveaway for movie
tickets when we get a little bit closer too
all the fans of classic Transformers just
pointing at the screen doing the Leonardo
DiCaprio meme like ah they're finally
doing Unicron planet on planet violence
proceed your way to Oblivion just starting with
the important stuff though when Optimus primal
is telling Optimus Prime about what's going on
like Unicron is the real threat here we need to
be worried about the end of all living things it
is a little bit weird that Optimus Prime being a
prime doesn't know about Unicron this footage
with this glowing Jewel shooting energy into
the sky that might be a version of the all
spark which is kind of like their version of
The Matrix of leadership inside the Transformers
Universe like a piece of Primus Unicron and his
twin brother Primus are sort of like the twin
gods of the Transformer Multiverse Unicron is
more of like a dark god of the Transformers and
Primus is like the light side God creator of all
Transformers that includes all factions of the
Transformers like all the autobots as well as
the Decepticons the Predacons the maximals every
different version of Transformers that evolved
over time so them doing Unicron is sort of them
going back to the origin of the Transformers
Multiverse they actually she just announced
that they're actually doing a movie about the
origin of the Autobots and the Decepticons called
Transformers 1 with Chris Hemsworth of all people
playing young Optimus Prime they'll also probably
use some of that movie to explain the origin of
Cybertron as well as the origin of Primus and his
brother Unicron we see Unicron in his Planet form
getting ready to consume another planet he looks
just like he did in the Classic Series in the
classic movie remember though this is just one
of his forms like you do actually see his eyes
like he does start transforming in later parts of
the trailer this is one of his other forms like he
can take a couple different forms if you're not
a big fan of Transformers the closest I could
compare him to would be like a version of Galactus
inside the Transformers Multiverse his whole thing
is that he wants to consume all life which is
also kind of funny because they just announced
that Galactus is probably going to be in this new
Marvel Fantastic Four movie that they're going to
be doing the next couple of years rolling really
hard on planet-sized characters basically Unicron
consumes other planets other worlds other Suns
to make more energy that's how he continues to
survive but his real goal is to get rid of the
Multiverse so that everything will return to the
black nothingness of chaos that existed before
the birth of the Multiverse before the Big Bang
you see the teeth formed from what is kind of
like his mouth getting ready to consume a planet
this is the scene of Peter dinklish's Scourge
character who's the leader of the terror cons
who've allied with Unicron against the autobots
and everybody that's on planet Earth this is him
speaking to Unicron in front of one of his giant
eyes like this gives you an idea like he's about
the same size as Optimus Prime so that gives
you an idea of the scale there's a scene of
the characters teasing that there might be some
way to actually stop Unicron and them opening
this ancient portal here on the ground I'm not
totally sure what their solution is going to
be probably going to have something to do with
the allspark within the Transformers continuity
usually Primus was the only other being that was
powerful enough to stop Unicron himself and within
the live-action Transformers movies the all-spark
is sort of like a piece of primus's Divine Essence
Troy the autobot Matrix of leadership the only
thing that can stand in my way then they have this
giant three or four-way battle at the end because
there's one group that they don't actually show
in the trailer or at least I haven't seen them
in the trailer yet the actual synopsis teases
four main groups of all the different types of
Transformers from the Beast Wars period and the
modern period the Autobots the maximals from Beast
Wars the Predacons and the terracons the Predacons
are kind of like the Beast Wars version of the
Decepticons though remember during the movie
they're sort of combining some of the different
eras of Transformers from the TV shows during
the Beast Wars era the maximals were kind of like
the Autobots but they're basically saying in the
movie that the autobots and the maximals are
two completely different groups of characters
it was the same thing with the Predacons and the
Decepticons so like Megatron was a purple dinosaur
as part of the Predacons but I don't know how
they're going to explain that during this movie
because I haven't seen a purple dinosaur anywhere
in any of the trailers yet I'm assuming at some
point there'll be some teaser for him in the movie
but the whole idea here in this big final battle
is that they're all going at each other and it
seems like a portion of the battle will take place
on unicron's body like you see his giant body all
around them here just to explain unicron's origin
story though it's actually a pretty cool creation
myth within the Transformers Multiverse if you're
not up on the lore of Transformers they've reconed
the backstory of the Transformers a bunch of times
but in the most current Incarnation Unicron is
more like primus's older twin brother the dark
god of the Multiverse Unicron came before a Primus
and it was sort of like an Adam and Eve story from
the Bible the being who created Unicron is
called The Source or the one which they've
referred to many times in the live action movies
as well as the Animated Series the animated movie
You Got The Touch it's the source of all life in
the source of all life within the Transformers as
well the source was sort of like an extra
dimensional being that existed before the
birth of the Multiverse he's meant to be like a
singularity that existed before all of creation
his body contained the pure Primal forces of
ordering chaos existing in pure Harmony then
the Big Bang happens the Multiverse is born in
the source creates Unicron in order to explore
the universe and discover New Creations Sun's
planets everything sort of like the celestials
inside the Marvel Universe Unicron and his twin
brother Primus are both multiversal beings as
well meaning that there's only one version of
them in the entire Multiverse but the difference
is that Unicron has to physically move between
different universes whereas Primus can exist in
all universes simultaneously the first major era
of the Transformers Multiverse is referred to as
the age of gods of light and darkness is sort of
like a Lord of the Rings backstory where during
the first age you have a bunch of gods going
to war with each other at the beginning of
time the source watched Unicron going around
the Multiverse exploring he noticed that he
would consume everything kind of like Galactus
in the Marvel Universe like I said because the
source didn't want this he didn't intend for
Unicron to consume everything he takes from
unicron's body and creates Primus giving him the
power to stop Unicron from consuming everything
Primus becomes the leader of this group of ultra
powerful Cosmic entities called The Light Side
gods they go to war with Unicron who's leading a
group of what they call the dark side Gods Primus
eventually defeats Unicron trapping them both on
the physical plane in an asteroid in Primus then
turns his body into the actual Planet Cybertron
creating the Transformers he passes a portion of
his Divine energy into all the Transformers that
he creates as well as the Matrix of leadership
which the primes passed down in the form of the
all-spark during the Transformers live action
movies the Autobots the Decepticons all the other
different factions of Transformers are just part
of the group of Transformers that Primus created
so he is essentially their maker in the the reason
why in the present day of all the Transformers
movies you don't see Primus talking to the other
Transformers Optimus Prime or really doing much
of anything is because he goes into self-impose
Exile going dormant so that Unicron can't detect
him and find a way back to the universe typically
in present day Unicron relies on alliances with
lesser Transformer factions in the movie that's
the Terracon led by Peter dinklage's Scourge
but he also has a mental link with his twin
brother Primus and he can use that against
him so the whole idea is that Unicron is
too powerful for the Transformers to actually
destroy him completely but they can get rid of
him temporarily which it sounds like is what's
probably going to happen during the movie like
they will be able to stop him from destroying
the entire Earth but they won't absolutely
destroy him if there's any other big Easter eggs
or references that you saw in the trailer footage
that I didn't address in the video just write
them Below in the comments I'll try to do more
videos for the movies we get more footage there
were a bunch of other trailers that came out
this past week a bunch of first looks and teasers
I'll try to do videos for everything as quickly
as possible be sure to enable olders for my
channel so you don't miss that everyone click
here for my Guardians of the Galaxy 3 review
and click here for that brand new Flash movie
trailer thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and I'll see you guys in the next one!